why did you say you showed him one of
your early journals and you had written
down the words proud Mary was like one
of the first things you ever wrote down
right in your journal yeah what is that
I mean that was just late in the crowd
Mary come from I don't know it just came
to you yeah the sound of proud mary I
didn't know what it meant
yeah how old is that Journal I bought
this thing in 1967 right and you just
jotted down the first thing in the
journal the very first thing says proud
mary that's correct yeah I came home you
know I said I got to get more organized
instead of just shuffling around to
buying a piece of paper yeah so the
first thing I actually wrote said song
titles of course all the pages were
blank
but you had a little organizer that said
song title right what was the very first
thing you know after a few days you know
I said what I said was I got to start
keeping track of these titles and these
ideas yeah a few days went by and one
day I'm just out of the blue I'm proud
Mary yeah that's cool so that's the very
first thing I wrote here but I didn't
know what it meant I didn't even know
what it was you know what is that so
proud Mary is that the process sometimes
[ __ ] just comes to you and you go hmm
wait I'm proud Mary that could be a cool
song title I don't you know I don't know
and you file it away and then yes and
then when you need a song you go okay
Proud Mary